[Music]
the green-screen competition has been
finished here are the winning contestant
but before before we begin I want to
announce a new competition check out the
link in the description
I want you bros to submit your best
PewDiePie means try and make them funny
clever and relevant it could be anything
just don't make any of that cringey
garbage that I know so many of you
submitted for the green-screen
competition no offense I appreciate all
my friends content without any exception
except all that [ __ ] cringy [ __ ] hey
as a relief in here
trigger warning it's gonna go from
absolute [ __ ] to amazing they edited
you're probably gonna be better off not
watching this video that actually goes
for all my videos but regardless so
check this out I love simple but
effective that Marcio action needs to be
a minute [ __ ] sake what is this
supposed to be
you think you're funny you think I
didn't think you would oh my god what is
this oh boy I think I know where this
draw our nation I'm your host Keuka
killer keemstar
[Laughter]
why is it fun it was so bad but it was
so good I don't know
[ __ ] hell very creative I like it I
love these by the way I think it this is
so much fun
alright let's keep watching some work
[Music]
I didn't remember that well I was part
of that movie
no it's hard to grab it and just good
hurts a little bit
oh my god there's another one
so good so far I love it
[Music]
so good I love when I mean [ __ ] I
shouldn't be in oh my god definitely not
Sonic
there's no one faster than me there oh
wow that's a pretty good use of green
screen right there this is cool man
it's some funky [ __ ] I can get into how
it landed yeah I'm not part of this
space program what can I say in this is
big investment they wanted to go with
the celebrity a big name you know behind
you there's nothing mysterious about it
it's just how I get into the room I mean
[Music]
that is true he does keep me in the
closet what is this I don't know
honestly oh my god what the hell baby
huh what the [ __ ] oh that's what happens
this is the footage when Jack saw me for
the first time what what they're taking
all the grunts that I did what the [ __ ]
made with chem Stasia free trial Wow I
[Music]
can't tell if this is ironic or just the
purest form of camp
[Music]
did you just make yourself get [ __ ] by
me what that that is some weird [ __ ] man
that is some weird [ __ ] I don't keep
it up this is [ __ ] awesome Lee made
look at that that was impressive man
what the hell that's not a horse
[Music]
is fighting laterz peso jacuzzi I don't
have a youtube subscriber try white
[Music]
love you yeah you hold you better
brofist from French that was awesome so
creative good [ __ ] man
you want to see magic trick yes I can
fly
Oh perfect song perfect good [ __ ] Super
Smash Bros special edition where am i oh
there am i okay great hell yeah
[Music]
that's what bouncer [ __ ] you these are
very awesome and creative I'm really
really impressed
[Music]
whoo papa pants
[Applause]
okay unexpect songs to come out of this
that's so cool you want to see magic
trick oh yeah I was part of the revenant
I completely forgot about it tonight
this is actually a dream of mine
Oh No oh my god I know I don't know man
you show your face around these parts
Malcolm Malcolm you're dead to me don't
worry we've prepared a special ritual
for you that looks so real I've gone
through half of them I'm gonna have to
split this one into two parts because
it's gonna go on way too long but just
huge huge thanks to everyone that's
submitted I am so impressed by this
round of green-screen submissions I love
these kind of videos because we are
doing it together and I think it's so
cool thank you everyone for
participating
I'll make part 2 in the meanwhile you
all can start doing memes and [ __ ] we
cut so much like if you're just gonna
submit a shitty one make it a funny
shitty one all right leave a like if you
enjoyed thank you so much for watching
and as always rose you're awesome say
yes
[Music]
big buddies ah oh [ __ ] what am I gonna
do
resetting guess that's not a race I'm
good man yeah
[Applause]